[Musik]
also haben erklärt mal erklär ja wir
haben ein cookieen dann haben wir einen
richtig saftigen Schokokuchen BR mäßig
also bisschen death bei chocolate
angelehnt noch mal die fluffy
Marshmallow cream und top kenst du diese
diese Instagram Videos die so richtig
FPN Schrei si gerade
aus
[Musik]
Schicht Nummer ein Cookie Dough und da
kommtische
[Musik]
Aufnahme der cookied Teig ist sehr
schnell zubereitet wichtig ist dass ihr
eine Sache vorbereitet und zwar das Mehl
in der Pfanne anrüsten denn Mehl ist ja
ein Naturprodukt und so sterben dann
mögliche Bakterien etc ab so und da gibt
jetzt einfach in eine Schüssel zimmerwe
Butter Zucker mit dazu braunen
Rohrzucker und weißen Zucker Vanille
exakt könnt ihr da auch schon gerne mit
dazu geben und ich schreibe euch
natürlich alle ganz genauen
Mengenangaben unten in die Infobox da
müsst ihr euch jetzt hier nichts merken
so das Ganze einmal durchrühren Milch
und Mehl dazu geben und dann könnt ihr
gerne auch noch Schokodrops dazu tun
denn ich finde dann hat erst so diesen
richtigen cookieo
[Musik]
Charakter
nach dem cookiedoo folgt der
[Musik]
Schokokuchen so ich verwende jetzt meine
Küchenmaschine ihr könnt natürlich auch
euer handrühgerät verwenden aber das
nimmt mirach viel Arbeit ab und ich habe
jetzt hier auch kein schneebesenaufsatz
sondern das rührelement mit der
Gummilippe damit ich jetzt auch die
ganze Butter immer wieder vom Rand
mitnehme die Butter sollte zimmerwarm
sein da kommt jetzt Zucker mit dazu und
gerne auch schon Vanilleextrakt das
ganze dann ca 3 Minuten lang mixen und
dann die Eier mit dazu
[Musik]
geben so die Eier sind jetzt mit dem
Teig und jetzt fehlen noch unsere
trockenen Zutaten da habe ich Mehl ganz
viel Backkakao und Backpulver und das
gebe ich einmal durch mein Sieb und ganz
zum Schluss kommt einfach nur noch
Joghurt mit hinein und ich habe mir
gedacht weil das ja schon so ein richtig
schokoladiger Teig wird pimpe ich den
einfach noch mit Schokodrops die gebe
ich dann ganz zum Schluss auch noch mit
[Musik]
dazu
ich habe jetzt einen Tortenring auf 20
cm eingestellt und in Backpapier
eingeschlagen das ganze auf mein
Backblech gegeben der Ofen ist auch
schon vorgeheizt auf 180° Ober und
Unterhitze aber ich schreibbe euch alle
Infos wie gesagt noch mal in die
Videobeschreibung und jetzt kommt der
Teig einmal hier rein der Teig ist jetzt
schon so satisfying und dann wird er
einmal vollständig gebacken und auch
kühlen gelassen und dann geht's
eigentlich schon zur
[Musik]
Zusammensetzung und jetzt folgt die
dritte
Schicht fluffy
Marshmallow
[Musik]
ich habe mir einfach immer gedacht ich
habe so geniale Ideen damit und ich
brauche einfach ein leckeres Marshmallow
Fluff was ihr bei mir im Onlineshop
bekommen könnt es ist komplett ohne
tierische Gelatine und es schmeckt nicht
so süß wie euch das jetzt wahrscheinlich
vorstellt weil es ist ja
schaumzuckermasse es ist geil aber es
schmeckt nicht so süß wie man sich das
jetzt vielleicht vorstellen mag und
daraus könnt ihr so viele geniale te
zaubern und ihr werdet auch ganz viel
Inspiration von mir bekommen und ich
würde mal sagen ein Löffelchen genehmige
ich mir jetzt und dann zeige ich euch
wie das mit der Torte weitergeht m und
jetzt werden die drei Komponenten nur
noch zusammengesetzt das geht ganz
einfach indem ihr euch hier einmal den
cookied nimmt geh ich einfach direkt auf
die Tortenplatte ihr könntet auch ein
cakeboard unten drunter tun falls ihr
jetzt gerade nicht wisst welche
Tortenplatte ihr verwenden sollt oder
kein Platz im Kühlschrank habt gibt's ja
auch so und da lege ich jetzt einfach
meinen Tortenring drum herum auf 20 cm
bzw ihr könnt ja auch so ein bisschen
mehr als 20 nehmen denn der Plan ist es
jetzt diesen Cookie Teig doppelt
gemoppelt cookieo den gibt jetzt einfach
auf den Boden und gleichzeitig auch so
ein bisschen an den Rand und legt dann
quasi den Schokoboden hier einmal rein
und ich möchte halt das optisch einfach
was hermcht indem man auch sieht von
außen wenn er noch nicht angeschnitten
ist ah okay da verbingt sich auch noch
cookieo
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt oben und an den Seiten
alles mit dem fluffy Marshmallow
verstrichen und jetzt würde ich mal
sagen es ruft ruft nach
flambation flamb flambiererei keine
Ahnung auf jeden Fall es ruft danach
flambiert zu werden und das machen wir
jetzt auch
das sieht gut
[Musik]
aus
so sieht das fertige Ergebnis aus ich
habe jetzt nich den hams noch gerufen
für den Taste Test oh
mein oh gotten g alles gut vergiss es oh
mein Gott kennst du diese diese
Instagram Videos die so richtigpn
schreiben sieh das gerade aus und
genauso wollte ich das auch wir haben
ein cookieen coden sieh man schon dann
haben wir einen richtig saftigen
Schokokuchen Brown mäßig so Brownie
mäßig ist aber nicht ganz also bisschen
death be chocolate angelehnt ist nicht
oben noch mal Kalorien draf ja istch mal
die fluffy Marshmallow cream on top also
sag mal das ist echt che Kuchen ich find
hier muss man auch mal den Kopf
abschalten und gen und ich denke wenn
ich es durchrechne ist bestimmt gar
nicht so schlim aber das sieht aber
optisch auch wirklich richtig gut aus al
richtig hübsch wirklich au das Stück so
es ist richtig soft warum hast du das
dann so und ich habe so ich habte zwei
verschiedene Stile man gleitet richtig
gut durch also fluffy schich ist sowieso
mega mega fluffig und dann hat man hier
diesen soften Kuchen und cookieo ist ja
auch weich also es ist die Kombination
aber ich dass der Schoko TE nicht so süß
ist du siehst eine augenscheinliche
Kalorienbombe aber es ist gar nicht so
ich habe auch Joghurt im Teig der KCK
ist auf je bisschen süßer als als der
also als der schokoteil aber mit dem
Marshmallow passt das auf jeden Fall
also ihr dürft euch das jetzt nicht
vorstellen oh richtig süß und so habe
ich ja euch gerade auch schon zum fluffy
Marshmallow erzählt das ist nicht so
s ich fin auch so richtig cool mit dem
mit dem Boden zweise hätte jetzt normal
Boden gemacht ohne Boden hätte auch
schon gereicht aber das gibt noch mal so
richtiges SM SM und genau daing daran
habe ich gedacht ich habe gedacht der
wird mich weghauen der ist ja richtig
süß ist aber so si ja gar nicht ja gar
nicht ist wirklich nicht so richtig
angenehm
süß also ist auch wieder nicht oder nein
überhaupt nicht revidiert jetzt alles
ehrlich das ist mega ich fin Hammer das
M und die Marshmallow
Topping ist ja auch nicht so dick das
ist relativ dünn sieht jetzt so massisch
aus aber es ist sehr dünn es ist sehr
dünn und ganz ehrlich ich kannst sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr von der
Marshmallow Schicht vertragen weil das
verteilt sich ja mit alle mit allen
Schichten ey wir sind begeistert oder
also allgemein auch unsere
marshmallowceme ja es ist eine
marschmallreme ja die ist bisschen süß
aber so ist die gar nicht Vergleich zu
anderen die sind wirklich die kann man
auch so einfach Löffeln jetzt nicht ganz
pischer ich habe richtig viele Ideen
damit Leute hast Du toll gemacht Kiki
danke schön also optisch ein 10 von ze
soll ich sagen ne danke schön mack ze
von ze und eine Sache muss man finden
jetzt gar nicht ich fin auch so mit
richtig schön das passt farblich stolz
stolz sein macht nach wenn jemand
Geburtstag hat e das ist einfach mal
eine richtig geile Geburtstagstorte oder
einfach so mach einfach nach das ist
echttig un jetzt noch im Team würde mal
sagen bis zum nächsten Mal ihr Lieben
tchü
[Musik]
ciao
ه